et vous dites j'ai fait des films j'ai
écrit des livres j'ai pris des coups
souvent mais de toutes les choses qui me
sont arrivées Christophe Rocancourt fut
la pire
et c'est une chose c'est pas un homme
ils accueillons notre invité du samedi
20h Catherine Briat bonsoir vous
racontez dans votre livre témoignage
abus de faiblesse l'arnaque dont vous
avez été victime de la part de
Christophe Rocancourt donc vous venez de
recevoir le Prix Pigeon d'Or de l'année
s'il était vraiment en or ce serait
formidable on en parlera à 20h Catherine
[Musique]
Catherine Bayard bonsoir donc cinéaste
écrivain 13 films dont Amazon parfaite
amour romance vous avez collaboré avec
Fellini et piala en 2007 vous
représentiez la France à Cannes avec une
vieille maîtresse et vous dites j'ai
fait des films j'ai écrit des livres
j'ai pris des coups souvent les miflégi
a fait de moi un demi cadavre mais de
toutes les choses qui me sont arrivées
Christophe Rocancourt fut la pire
et c'est une chose c'est pas un homme
alors d'abord les miflégi donc ça
commence en 2004
au réveil vous croyez morte ça vous a
pris comment comme ça je me suis
réveillé j'avais cette main qui me
paraissait morte et j'avais vraiment
l'impression que c'était la main de ma
mère morte qui est agrippait mon j'ai
essayé de me lever je suis tombé bon moi
je suis quelqu'un d'assez
efficace alors je vous le voyez pas
pourquoi j'arrivais pas à me lever j'ai
fini par remplir sur le lit et là
effectivement c'est très très rigolo les
trucs avec le SAMU c'est vraiment un
sketch on tombe beaucoup quand on est
hémiplégique vous vous êtes cassé deux
bras et le poignet quand même oui
et même sur Barbe Bleue je me suis
cassée aussi
toutes les dents j'ai fait tout le film
en noir jaune
il continue à travailler c'est une force
de caractère absolument incroyable
vous avez fait deux films
vous avez beaucoup de courage parce que
vous dites c'est difficile de rire avec
la bouche tordue je voulais rire donc
vous êtes complètement rééduqué
aujourd'hui franchement il y a pas de en
fait
le visage hémiplégique parce qu'on me le
montrait pas mais moi je voulais pas
avoir une voix géniarde je voulais rire
parce que contrairement à ce qu'on croit
je ris toujours beaucoup moi sur le
plateau vous préparez un film qui
s'appelle bad love à ce moment là alors
le pitch de Bad love c'est un homme qui
entraînerait une femme magnifique une
star pour régner en conquérant
analphabète et souverain ce qui est
extraordinaire en toute cette histoire
c'est qu'en fait ce que vous avez vécu
après dont on va parler
dans le casting au départ vous avez
prévu Naomi Campbell et pour le mec vous
cherchez un type un peu un peu rustre un
peu genre Harvey Keitel et là un jour
vous regardez mon émission sur France 2
qu'est-ce que j'ai fait là
et là vous voyez Christophe Rocancourt
et vous dites j'ai trouvé mon acteur oui
vous l'appelez et là il commence déjà il
vous dit je suis dans ma suite au
Normandie à Deauville dans une heure
j'ai un hélico pour me Gève et vous vous
savez très bien qu'il y a pas des ports
à Deauville j'étais
mais bon ça me fait rire mais il me
prend pour une idiote dès le départ la
première chose qui vous dit dans votre
relation déjà c'est un mensonge oui mais
ça je pensais que c'était un mensonge de
gamins en fait finalement de de gamins
qui comprend pas qui va pas être cru
lors de votre première rencontre vous
dites finalement il est pas très beau
vous dites même plus loin dans le
bouquin il a une phase de rat vous
trouvez vraiment qu'il y a une phase de
rat oui mais ça c'est parce que moi
j'aime bien les mots et face de rat dans
le dictionnaire je lui ai expliqué
d'ailleurs parce que je dis que tu seras
pas capable d'ouvrir un dictionnaire
alors je vais te dire face de rate en
français étymologique ça mal fera de
second tordre et sordide est-ce que
c'est ce que tu es et par extension
c'est
quelqu'un de méprisable vous le trouvez
pas très beau donc face de rat et il est
en retard à la première rencontre il
vous dit mon père était un gitan et ma
mère était une [ __ ] quand même
vous auriez dû vous méfier encore ah non
bon moi j'aime les gitans c'est quand
même le mec tu le croises au bout de 5
minutes tu sais que tu as à faire au
plus grand Charlot de l'histoire c'est
ça qui est extraordinaire
alors ce qui est extraordinaire c'est
que ce type qui ne croule pas sous les
propositions cinématographiques vous dit
bah pour le scénar je vais lire il faut
que je réfléchisse etc alors qu'il s'est
à peine lire une carte de restaurant
vous dites les 10 lettres de son nom il
sait lire ce qui est pour lui est un
jouet star dès le départ ça ça vous a
plu bah oui plaignez vous et et vous a
demandé 100000 euros de plus que vous
donniez un Naomi Campbell on y était pas
puis bon il était pas forcément choisi
ça coûte rien de dire oui
alors là vous tombez amoureuse de lui
c'est pas la même chose je dirais un
amour enfantin pas un amour de femme
enfin vous tombez quand même un peu
amoureuse de lui vous craquez pour lui
quand même mais c'est l'amour que tout
metteur en scène a aussi pour tout à
fait pour son personnage tout à fait ça
c'est très important il y a jamais eu de
sexe avec lui
je sais pas il a voulu rentrer dans mon
lit je lui ai dit jamais
je peux pas dire qu'il voulait me sauter
mais enfin pourquoi vous voulez-il
rentrer dans mon lit
qui est une espèce de féministe avisé
comme ça vous tombez dans le panneau du
petit voyou quoi
[Rires]
c'est pas c'est beaucoup plus complexe
que ça un abus de faiblesse maître
spinner vous le dira
un moment donné l'avocat de Monsieur
Rocancourt et donc je me garderai bien
de porter un jugement après Chirac
Rocancourt
[Applaudissements]
s
tous les trucs de voyous qu'il disait je
lui balancer des Vans ça me faisait
hurler de rire au début ça vous amusez
beaucoup c'est sûr c'est ça le problème
donc son truc bah voilà c'est de
commencer par emprunter des petites
sommes puis voilà puis après on va pas
raconter tous les chèques que vous lui
avez fait à la sortie vous a pris quoi
850 000 € quand même
il a eu beaucoup beaucoup de chance
parce qu'il y a beaucoup de
circonstances il y a celles ou quand
même il vient me chercher à l'hôpital je
suis sous une drogue comme la drogue
viol c'est-à-dire qu'on ne sait pas ce
qu'on fait et on ne s'en rappelle
absolument pas on comprend quand on lit
le bouquin c'est à dire il est très
habile il devient ami avec avec les
victimes un ami nécessaire il vous
appelle tous les jours vous dites il
s'enroulent autour de moi comme une
liane quoi on peut plus s'en passer et
il fint la dépendance il vous appelle en
vous disant dis-moi que je serai ton
dernier amour toute façon il y a que vos
amis qui vous trahissent qui d'autre par
définition c'est un ami
bon alors c'est vrai que c'est la
méthode de Rocancourt j'aurais dû lire
son livre il décrit exactement en disant
c'est très facile il faut être devenir
amis avec quelqu'un après on lui demande
un grand grand service parce que on est
en très mauvaise posture on a besoin
d'argent tout de suite tout de suite
comme ça il a pas le temps de réfléchir
et un ami il aide son ami
c'est d'une simplicité alors il va très
loin quand même il vous invite 5 mois
dans l'appartement qu'il partage avec
Sonia Rolland et oui je pouvais même pas
il était plat très jusque là mes doigts
même toutes les phalanges donc je
pouvais pas mais avaler un comprimé j'en
ai beaucoup à prendre ça aussi ça rentre
en ligne de compte parce que les pigeons
ils sont pas drogués c'est vrai il vous
coupe votre viande enfin je veux dire
bon voilà il devient votre meilleur ami
il devient indispensable la vie avec
Sonia Tess et Christophe quand il était
là
était c'est vrai
j'ai été très heureuse
alors sauf qu'à un moment il finira
quand même par vous menacer de mort donc
on voit bien le retournement de du
personnage je vous jure que quand il
menace
la voix alors là c'est plus la voix
vulgaire et c'est vraiment la voix du
tueur du truc en quoi et malgré tout on
peut dire ce qu'on veut mais c'est une
magnifique histoire avant qu'elle se
termine mal j'ai vu que c'était une
magnifique histoire qu'est-ce que vous
voulez moi je suis une artiste alors
voilà vous finissez par lui échapper
Vous portez plainte pour abus de
faiblesse auprès alors c'est très drôle
auprès de la brigade de répression de la
délinquance astucieuse vous savez pas
que ça existait c'est extraordinaire
et vous dites vous dites Catherine
j'espère qu'il ira en prison
oui ça lui conviendrait quand même alors
vous dites c'est un serial ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire que
c'est quelqu'un de déshumaniser qui n'a
pas d'humanité même pour lui-même moi je
crois que la première fois où il me voit
pour lui ça s'est mis en marche
dès le premier moment il a décidé que la
lactique qui attendait depuis longtemps
aller boum tomber sur la croix quoi je
suis le moyen
d'assouvir sa pulsion comme un serial
sauf que les céréales killer violeurs la
pulsion est assouvie en une fois et là
où c'est beaucoup plus complexe c'est
que effectivement ça s'installe dans une
durée alors c'est vrai que c'est un type
bon voilà il dépouille les gens
que ce soit pour Monsieur Rocourt pour
n'importe qui ça serait bien que dans
les émissions tout le monde respecte la
présomption d'innocence mais c'est pas
parce qu'il a été condamné une fois aux
USA qui les coupables de tout ce qui
fera mais je le dis pour Christophe
Rocquencourt je le dis pour tout le
monde c'est bien de respecter la
position
vous lui avez donné c'est de l'argent en
fait qui était des avants sur son
salaire d'acteur il n'a pas joué il n'a
pas de contrat et de toute façon un
contrat si vraiment veut retenir un
acteur mais le plus grand du monde c'est
10% en tout cas vous aujourd'hui vous
avez plus d'argent
non donc j'avais perdu tout ce que vous
avez gagné dans votre vie Catherine
vous allez vivre comment maintenant moi
je travaille tout le temps de toute
façon si je ne suis pas en train de
travailler je meurs surtout surtout
si vous l'aviez en face de vous comme ça
mais je leur ai pas en face de moi
puisque je verrai un nuage de coton une
baudruche dégonflée je vois pas ce que
je pourrais lui dire puisque c'est pas
une personne
bon dis-moi alors toi tu en penses quoi
de tout ça oh non parce que la fameuse
phrase plus le mensonge est gros plus il
est facile à faire avaler si tu veux et
moi j'en reviens pas parce que
Christophe Rocancourt surtout pour notre
génération il y a eu des livres des
reportages on te dit attention escroc
mais Sonia Rolland est tombé dans le
panneau aussi si tu veux c'est comme si
demain tu cherches un banquier tu vas
contacter Bernard Madoff c'est
exactement pareil quoi tu cherches
vraiment le plus gros escroc en sachant
que tu vas perdre forcément c'est là où
c'est c'est particulièrement troublant
quoi
très intéressant
je vous adore vous savez que la dernière
nouvelle il cherche à joindre mousse
Diouf
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
Inna larditube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu